if the government came along to your
street to your town and said to you and
everyone who lives there you have to
move we need this would you go would you
accept it because that's what happened
here in the abandoned Village of IM on
Salsbury plane in the Years leading up
to World War II the war office who
commanded the Army back then had
steadily bought all the land around IM
along with almost all the buildings in
the village they convinced farmers and
residents to sell their property and
rent it back on leases that had to be
renewed annually it helped that there
was a depression and the was offering a
fair price Salsbury plane became the
largest military training area in the
country by the 1940s as the second world
war escalated the land around the
village was used constantly for military
training and having to make sure the 150
or so civilians living in this Village
weren't hit by shells or accidentally
shot started to get in the way of that
training not to mention that the troops
preparing for the D-Day Landings needed
to prepare for fighting in small rural
Villages so in 1943 the residents were
given about 7 weeks notice to leave at
first it was temporary just for 6 months
then it was until the war ended and then
suddenly it was permanent a legal battle
rolled on until 1961 and ultimately it
was decided that IM belonged to the Army
and that the residents would never be
allowed to return most of the houses had
been destroyed in generic modern
simulations of houses have gone up in
their place and again this wasn't some
ancient time some old centuries past ERA
this is easily in living memory but
there were some concessions made the
road through would be kept open for a
few days a year and the church built
around 700 years earlier would still be
able to have services at Christmas
Easter and a couple of other times there
is a Latin proverb written by Cicero
enter armor enim seant legus in time of
war the law Falls silent now it's been
used to comment on America's internment
of Japanese Americans in World War II
despite the first and fifth amendments
and on extraordinary rendition and
torture despite international law in
more recent times but this here was more
subtle here the law didn't fall silent
it just spoke in a rather different
voice because this wasn't illegal this
wasn't a government bending laws and
regulations to their breaking point or
Beyond back at the end of the 30s as war
in Europe began to look inevitable the
British government passed the emergency
Powers Act the ACT allowed the king and
therefore the government to create
regulations as necessary to help the war
effort and to enforce those regulations
by any punishment including in the worst
case death it allowed anyone to be
detained in the interests of Public
Safety or defense of the realm and
allowed any trial to be held in secret
it also allowed property to be searched
and seized at will by the standards of
what was possible under the law IM was
treated well now I don't know whether
that could ever happen again and whether
in this Century in this country a
village of people would for the most
part quietly leave their homes to help
the war effort but I will say this there
are still similar emergency Powers laws
on the books albeit with a few more
checks and balances and only for use in
times of absolute crisis but I do wonder
how much Panic it would take to find the
government quietly reaching for those
Powers again and with most of the public
supporting them I don't think we've
changed that much in the last
century